hey y'all this is Blake Shelton what is
it called again
hey y'all this is Blake Shelton and
you're watching certified country with
Sophie Salette she almost died say it
wrong hey y'all this is Blake Shelton
you're watching certified country with
Sophie she lacy nailed it happy Friday
welcome to certified country I'm Sophia
Lacey and that was a flashback to 2017
when I sat down with Blake at the grand
opening of his ol red restaurant in
Tishomingo Oklahoma now you may have
heard that Blake is opening a second and
third location of ole red in Nashville
and Gatlinburg Tennessee and of course
right now he's vying for another win on
the voice so today I thought it would be
super fun to revisit some of my favorite
interviews with mr. Shelton over the
years for a very special flashback
Friday edition of the show I know you
are Smith work we live on what do you
just drink that straight or do you have
something in there it doesn't really
matter does it no cocktails for you
today Brad no it's a just for the
viewers watching home it's 10:00 at
10:00 in the morning I mean there's a
bar you can get a Bloody Mary over here
I want yeah oh yeah we're gonna get one
[Music]
just talking about my liver your livers
show makes me drink a lot fact I need a
drink right now
what style inspiration mr. Rogers what's
the likelihood are you working with this
guy you know what he just did he just
totally wrote himself off from greatness
that's what he just did just this minute
from the greatest song he was about to
ever write actually I was the thought of
you actually ever speaking to me again
once you're done with this show I think
this show is gonna put me on yeah that
might be because Blake and Adam won't
give each other any peace what's going
on over there well they're ganging up on
you again hey anybody know where Waldo
is anybody anybody seen Waldo you guys
can't even keep it together across the
room you can you love that guy don't you
I'm thankful that Adam grew his hair
back because he was starting to look
like Squidward but now he looks more
like Eddie Munster again that guy was
mean I'm not kidding
thousands I bet he owes me six or seven
thousand dollars worth of vets and he
doesn't deliver Oh oh my god and it's
amazing how he doesn't he's like oh not
in shape we never shook on that it's
like those he's one he's that guy yeah
Andy's stupid-looking
another thing Blake and Brad agree on
their favorite coach so you can just
tell me who would you rather be with I
got a bad feeling because because when
Stefan is on this show so don't ask him
that because ya know it's probably
picked glam that's the best job did you
have a hard time getting people to agree
to go on Team Blake when you've got Gwen
sitting next to you well I know who I
would have picked if I was them you know
for the record guys that interview was
done in early July of 2015 which
well before Blake and Gwen officially
even got together since then though it's
safe to say that things have changed and
Blake and I have talked a lot about that
relationship
hey Blake you look very handsome today
thank you so do you are you dressed up
for Gwen
Hannah you know when I originally
started writing this song that we're
performing than that I was only trying
to impress when that time around - I
mean look at you like to be born with
her genetics it's not fair when told me
earlier she said everyday for her is
like Valentine's Day I doubt that that
comes from him but that should be the
way it is does she make you feel like
the luckiest guy every day yeah I mean
have you seen her yeah have you seen me
tell me I'm the luckiest guy last week
we didn't have you guys we were with
Gwen and Adam and we asked them what
they were thankful for in their fellow
coaches they had an interesting response
for you Blake like I've been Oleg for
too long
Blake is my buddy there's Kenny I love
you Blake kinda yes sometimes I love -
Blake ish they both love me they both
love me feel so special I'm thankful for
Gwyn for tons of reasons but mostly just
because she makes us all look about the
album - and the cut with Gwen I hesitate
to brag on it too much but I really
think that it's just good of a song as
I've ever written in my life I can't
wait to hear it
tell me about writing it how did it come
together were you guys at home did you
sit down in the studio like with the
goal of writing oh you wish you knew
don't you wish you knew where we were
how we wrote it started this song and
wrote about half of it and sent it to
her and and she wrote the other half of
it most of the vocals for this thing
we're done in my closet my producer came
and set up as you know makeshift studio
and we had my microphones and stuff and
the hardest part was not smiling you
know throughout the whole thing when we
were singing it because it was just we
can't believe this is happening
we still can't believe it's happening we
have so much fun I don't think you
should be able to have that much fun
it's probably not legal in California
probably not I think Blake's always been
a great sport even when the questions
get tough now I won't ask you about the
album in a second but I have to ask you
do you do you see yourself having more
kids not strong how we wrap it all right
well I asked okay like I read here used
to be a pageant kid wait wait what I
read where you need to shut up yes I was
I was in pageants I was in pageants were
there are there even male pageants young
boy no there's not well my specialty
back then was cat scratch fever by Ted
Nugent yeah and that was before they had
karaoke tape so I just had to sing
louder than him on his own record and it
was it was magical this is the greatest
thing I've ever heard that's sad I you
know I wanted to bring it back what are
you teaching your voice contestants this
is what you were used to be a performer
don't lock your report yeah you better
settle down Missy the first time I've
seen you since the big sexiest man alive
tie it all has yours coaching style
become more sex
I mean it has done every good thing it
can do for me is like superpowers in the
beginning I know there was a lot of a
lot of opinions I've learned in the last
couple of years the social media is 80%
it's just absolute cruel cruel trolling
just and so when knowing that going into
it some that stuff's pretty funny I
gotta say I mean that someone's like a
jerk I'm like okay but that was pretty
fun I know thank you so much thank you
little buddy you gotta love like sense
of humor thank you guys so much for
watching if this is your first time with
us please subscribe to Entertainment
Tonight on YouTube and come back and see
us every Friday we've got brand new
episodes and interviews with Nashville's
biggest stars now I'll leave you today
with one last soundbite that pretty much
sums up my relationship with like
perfectly quick photo before I eat my
thank you for that she's just little
it's okay thanks big buddy